gilbert annette le maire de saint-denis
bon appétit 12h15 sur la première comme
promis lundi politique gay le dantec
reçoit aujourd'hui l'heure est elle
lundi politique
gaël le dantec
au mois de juin dernier la gestion de la
commune de sa venue avait été critiquée
par la chambre régionale des comptes
suscitant une série polémique un épisode
qu'il pourrait annoncer la couleur de la
campagne pour les élections municipales
de mars prochain
quelle stratégie pour la fin de mandat
pour le maire sortant selon sera-t-il
lui-même dans la bataille
in game vous dira pas aujourd'hui
visiblement encore mais sur le fond
quelle politique pour les marmailles
quel prix quel mode de déplacement
demain dans le chef-lieu quel logement
quelle réponse à l'urgence climatique à
la demande de démocratie
gibert est le médecin de lui conseiller
d'opposition d'inviter la vie politique
jusqu'à 13h vos questions à partir de
12h45 au 02 62 96 de ville bonjour merci
d'avoir c'était une autre invitation
dans l'actualité d'abord il ya cet
accident la première car c'est le jour
où un jeune garçon de nouveau été
percuté par un motard jeune motard
lorsque vous avez des nouvelles de ceux
de ce garçon oui ce garçon a été
transféré à saint pierre il était opéré
bon je voudrais d'abord évidemment
exprimer ma solitude la solidarité
pardon vis-à-vis de la famille s'est
vite cet enfant devant ma compassion et
de dire que ce qui est arrivé bien sûr
et est inadmissible c'est la conséquence
de ces rodéos 1 qui existe déjà sur deux
de ses passes est en cours alors mais si
c'est en tous les cas il y à des rodéos
et c'est un fléau
nous avons nous agit dans la mesure de
nos moyens sur le boulevard rambo sur la
rue roger b est les rodéos sont déplacés
et il appartient à l'état inquiète cette
responsabilité la sécurité publique de
prendre tous les moyens d'être ferme
vis-à-vis de ce fait de rennes qui bien
sûr crée des difficultés pour la
population la population du chaudron a
droit à la sécurité à sa tranquillité
comme la population de ces banlieues
françaises soit paris allemand où il ya
tous les week-ends et en dodon c'est un
phénomène qui qui qui est dangereux mais
pour lequel elle à l'élite à
vous en appelez à l'état parce que vous
au niveau communal vous ne pouvez pas
agir vous avez une peau lisse n'est pas
du tout les suisses pas n'est pas décidé
à ça c'est un phénomène qui nous dépasse
et dont nous nous sommes là pour alerter
ce que les moyennes la sécurité cet état
donc l'état
pas forcément l'état et c est pour
l'instant l'état n'a pas réussi à
éradiquer ce mal mais comme l'état n'a
pas réussi jouit dans une dizaine de
villes de banlieue en métropole aux
états unis donc nous sommes face à un
phénomène nouveau de rodéo par les
jeunes qui a traversé itunes sans doute
une contestation de révolte et de l'état
est en difficulté pour moi j'ai vite et
à redoubler de fermeté pour mettre en
sécurité la pollution ce que vous êtes
en contact avec moi je suis je vais
rencontrer demain le directeur de
sécurité publique monsieur lebon et nous
sur nous passons en revue tous les
toutes les questions de sécurité il ce
problème soit évoqué les pistes aussi
d'offrir à ces jeunes je dirais une
piste à allonger la piste de la jamaïque
je me disais mais force est de constater
qu'une partie des jeunes ne veut pas
d'une activité normalisée ils cherchent
autre chose et nous sommes en difficulté
et il est à je parle de sécurité essaie
de trouver leurs mains des et l'état du
mal vous dis ici il faudrait une
présence policière plus plus importante
non il faut aussi tout surtout
convaincre les parents de ces jeunes
d'une orgie auxquels ils s'exposent je
pense que ceux qui font des rondes aux
c'est très dangereux pour leur propre
vie et ils mettent en danger la vie des
autres dont 30 conscience il faut que
ceux qui son projet nous essayons par
l'association la police
j ai ce qui est des poursuites est ce
qui est absolument pas pas donné
beaucoup de détails mais je sais que le
jeune il ya de jeunes concernés qui ont
été évidemment qu'ils sont en garde à
vue qui répondent et c'est donc enquête
est en cours
j'ai pas tous les éléments mais bien sûr
l'état réagisse est ce qu'il faut c'est
empêcher que ça sera noël et ça devient
encore plus grave et c'est un vrai
risque
j'ai parlé dans l'actualité aussi cette
consultation que lui qui démarre
aujourd'hui pour le projet de tramway de
tao pour relier l'aéroport au barachois
c'est quoi l'idée c'est de remplacer le
tcc le bus à kehl dans le oui le bus est
limité sa purée donc c'est un projet
plus ambitieux bien sûr ça crame peu
réguliers moderne pour éviter si vous
voulez l'arrivée massive des voitures de
est un fait que le matériel
embouteillages aux et suit un
encombrement rallier le s'allient donc
nous avons opté pour le transport en
commun et le transport en commun tramway
c'est évidemment la bonne réponse donc
nous même de voter une motion au conseil
municipal disant que ce projet tao tao
est un projet qui nous convient nous le
préférons même au rail ou de voter pour
votre projet voté contre celui de la
région ce projet de la cinor sony sony
passe oui non nous considérons que il
est impossible réaliser deux projets non
dans le même temps est-ce que tu reviens
en projet la région qui est plutôt sur
le tracé du boulevard sud 1 puisque et
tandis que le projet du centre centre
vivre d'achat leclerc 5 l'outil le
centre-ville donc nous considérons que
deux frangins trop basse et un troc qui
coûte beaucoup c'est sous des projets
entre autres 350 400 livres dont nous
pensons que si on peut pas utiliser
l'argent public puisqu'il part du même
point un du palm oil
le barachois la caserne en mer nous
pensons qu'il faut choisir dans le temps
nous pensons que le premier projet celui
qui nous qui correspond le mieux aux
besoins de ces nids et qui va irriguer
le centre ville à qui va sonner la
population sans trembler pour
redynamiser sandrine c'était nous sommes
plutôt favorable à ce projet c'est ce
que le citoyen et le devenir qui va se
déplacer à caen sur arias deux projets
deux collectivités qui font des choses
en parallèle c'est à dire qu'il ya des
cabinets d'étude la conservation à ça
ressemble à quoi on va écouter la vous
pose un vrai problème les c'est un
problème qu'il échappe c'est le problème
de la région et de la cinor je pense
qu'aujourd'hui chaque fois comme chez
moi dans mon avis dont j'ai bien sûr
demandé aux deux collectivités de se
concerter qu'il était préférable d'avoir
un projet pourquoi
et bien parce qu'il faut aussi faire en
tramway
ça me dois ceni si on veut alléger moi
je considère comme ça vu de l'extérieur
que l'arche engageons vos maîtres sur le
rhône ride ancenis comme deuxième projet
ils feraient mieux de maintenant
depuis ça me noie chasser les
chaussettes li na est indispensable et
cette villa allègera diminuera
sensiblement le nombre de voitures
venant de l'est ce qui rentre
assainissent agora grande partie du
problème
et puis dans d'autres il faut faire
aussi eu ling saint-paul port ça dis
donc je pense que c'est 400 millions
d'agents pourrait dans un premier temps
utilisé ailleurs et laisser la cinor
faire ce projet qui correspond à reçoit
et voilà je mets ce tronçon a d'abord
d'avant je crois que la région a démarré
ce cette étude fait la région avait
démarré un projet qui s'appelle monorail
qui lui a
n'a pas abouti parce que les études de
faisabilité ont conclu que vous pouvez
parler donc si elle s'est retournée dans
ce projet là mais je pense aujourd'hui
la région sera pas je dirais opposé au
fait d'investir cet argent ailleurs
puisque l'idée de l'agencé dans le ca c
de joanes saint-benoît par le censeur
c'est une des dernières tendances de la
politisation politique locale surtout
que les projets sont portés par les
collectivités
une vision d'ensemble globale de la
relance est pour 3 ans dans une
situation de combat at war manque criant
de 2 200 sont quoi comment est-ce qu'on
va circuler dans saint denis dans cinq
ans dans dix ans ce qu'on fera encore
circuit ah oui je pense que ces projets
répondent nasa d'abord vous ayez ce
projet de tramway qui va apporter une
vraie réponse un beau chat libre jaleo à
jouer dans ces villes françaises n'en
existe pas ou le tramway à transfigurer
la ville et apporter des réponses à la
mobilité donc nous nous nous où nous
nous rejoignons ce mouvement avec une
population inférieure donc il faut
réussir
jorda avec le retard mais parce que
l'équation économique est différente ça
coûte très cher et on a moins de clients
donc voilà donc ça sympa nous aurons un
réseau téléphérique avec bien sûr la
première ligne breneck moufia gros noms
les travaux la première pierre weill ep
poser est ce mois-ci payer et payer ses
50 millions d'euros si nord kim et ce en
sommes donc tous a sonné sommes
importantes
ensuite une deuxième ligne intéressante
c'est la montagne belles pierres inquiet
aussi à les tuer qui démarra dans deux
ans on rails elle est toute une série
nous avons tout un projet déplacement
doit être logique
la première va être posée pour la
première ligne ça veut dire que le tracé
ça y est tout est arrêté on s'est
vraiment où pratiquement tous j'ai eu le
président bien sur jalle valliot je suis
ce projet ici on parle il ya encore une
difficulté mais je pense qu'elle va être
surmontés c'est qu'il ya une forme de
résistance ou d'opposition de
l'université sur le le le passage
prochain on retrouvera probablement un
compromis parce que c'est un projet
novateur voire révolutionnaire mon
inspiration vient de la colombie du
président sera donc ça correspond à
notre programme fit il faut y aller faut
pas tant vous disiez que nous allons
arrêter un plan vélo a fait un appel à
projets dont nous avons des opérateurs
qui se positionne nous aurons des sites
avec des vélos en location des vélos à
assistance électrique et nous avait une
chance sur des pistes vélodrome nous
inciterons les compris le personnel
mais bp des aides et subventions pour
faire de plus en plus de vélo parce que
les mots doux c'est excellent pour la
circulation et c'est bon pour la santé
aussi on traversera saint denis sans
compter un jour liora l'entrée ouest
finalisé on passera sous le sous la
ville savait tout ça ça fait beaucoup
plus fluide qu'aujourd'hui parce que sa
nostra clé vous savez que c'est pas pour
ça dit il développe penser développement
économique le tourisme par exemple les
hoquets rectrice se plaignent se
plaignent des embouteillages utre en
paires d'yeux et donc c'est frustrant
mais j'évoque le développement
économique en sont bien sûr ça pénalise
le développement économique de toute la
n'oubliez pas que entre l'aéroport et le
port ya beaucoup trafic donc nous sommes
en train d'apporter notre contribution
avec les la région et la cinor non mais
je fais de le dire parce que évidemment
tous qu'il s'agit aménagements n'avance
pas aussi vite qu'on soit très moi je
suis pro gay a elle constaté
et à le ressentir sauf que l'aménagement
exemple le boulevard sud en a mis 40 ans
pour faire donc les grands projets
projets d'aménagement quand on bouscule
l'urbanisme il faut du temps l'unité de
mesure c'est la d4 ses 10 ans et pas
tous les ans et je pense que jose règle
rapidement il faut du temps c'est vrai
il faut être patient c'est vrai mais ce
qui est important c'est que la réunion
on a fait quand même les différentes
collectivités leurs priorités qu on a
des projets qu'on a des finances parce
que le nerf de la guerre c'est des
financements et sur ses projets y est du
financement les travaux d'aménagement à
l'entrée le futur os de sa dette par
exemple qu'une impression mais crise on
va coûter des financements ce règne à
fontiers région gère un fonds qui
finance un pied taxe sur le trafic
ensuite les fonds européens et les
collectivités apportent une condition
c'est le fond qui tue la faune
particulier qui est alimenté qu'il taxe
sur le carburant qui alimente cette ce
faux et la région la compétence et à la
gestion se font au moins de 2 de début
mai les chocs fait prudent parce que
certains annonçaient calendrier qui me
paraît trop trop beau trop court moi je
veux pas tromper la population parce que
hier ce qu'on appelle les aléas chantier
sans arrêt dlr dont ce sont des choses
qui vont se faire dans les trois quatre
cinq ans dont il faut pas être trop
précis puisque on n'a pas la maîtrise
technique de ces chantiers compliqué
sera pas lancé un fond de teint à nos
ambitions a enclenché il ya des accords
et des conventions et des financements
mise en place sur le transport est mis
en place des transports gratuits pour
notamment pour les plus jeunes est ce
que ça peut se tromper ce que vous avez
aussi les projets de gratuité dans la
circulation dense en ont déjà il faut
porter c'est la gratuité
c'est à la fois les seniors un monsieur
il ya une partie de la population qui
manque de ressources à partir de 60 ans
et à 65 ans le transport en commun et
gratuit à sony ya maintenant de la
naissance à 19 ans en dessous de la
gratuité
donc ce sont des coûts importants
d'ailleurs fait allusion à change à
l'éco changera des comptes c'est
critiqué cette mesure de gratuité du
transport adapté nous c'est un choix
politique nous pensons que c'est
important la gratuité transport pour à
permettre aux jeunes d'être autonome de
s'épanouir d'avoir des activités de
bouger a donc nous continuerons bien sûr
vous fassiez sacoche à un sac ou sharp à
ce que sont les priorités de
développement des spas du snapo giverny
sans se soucier de circulation c'est
pour lutter contre les autres disent
aussi pour lutter contre la pollution
les rapports accablants au niveau
mondial e ce succès est à la planète et
notamment du climat la déforestation la
perte de biodiversité
on a le sentiment que les élus est
tétanisé face à ce que finalement le
court terme de l'echandole qui comporte
toujours sur terre et que je crois que
c'est une critique facile qui est
infondée
nous nous avons conçu des grands projets
pour régler sa dette
j'aimerais pas de choses l'air assainies
l'air et de qualité elle n'est pas
pollué donc nous avons des gros gros lot
est d'excellente qualité dans un rapport
sur l'eau et des soins de qualité
elle coule tous les jours et nous avons
un des prix les plus faibles d'europe 1
de france bien sûr et durable ou non
siem mauvaise information l'eau l'air
non nous sommes dans le long terme tous
ces projets savez sont des projets de
long terme des ferries etc l'aménagement
au contraire nous consacrons beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent à l'investissement
parce que nous savons très sysmans
prépare l'avenir
on est au beaucoup d'argent dans
l'investissement on vaut pas le coup
retient quand nous mettons 460
euros dans l'éducation sur dix ans c'est
phénoménal
aucune qu en france à notre échelle fait
ça ne nous avons des éléments de
comparaison
préparons le long terme réussir
l'éducation des enfants le ministre et
l'a lui-même a dit en face mais vous
êtes en train de la courneuve ce que nos
préconise vous avez déjà on va parler
reparler d'éducation il ya cette attente
vis-à-vis qui se sentent si votre
attente des citoyens au gala questions
environnementales depuis notamment
depuis les élections la démocratie
finalement les sites et les votes de
moins en moins d'un mois font de moins
en confiance aux élus font de moins en
moins confiance aux partis qui ont du
mal à recruter des militants est-ce que
vous voudrions croire à cette peau
cratie représentative et 6 me croise
qu'on peut le faire évoluer pour que les
gens sont saisis ce cas moi je crois que
ce mouvement des jeunes a été une vraie
expression
aux dunes inscrits d'une bonne part la
population et ça reflète bien l'état
dans quel sens à mes jeux
je n'ai rien à redire sur les constatent
les joséphistes contre 15 il ya pu y a
plus de cash au point de tuer n'est pas
du tout nous travaillons nous sur ce qui
est ressorti des points forts j'ai
jeunes remis en question évidemment la
représentativité la démocratie parti
nous travaillons sur d'autres mots nous
mêmes et nous allons améliorer ça nous
avons enclenché la démocratie
participative uniquement et j'ai je n'en
remets en cause par exemple s'ils
considèrent comme des privilèges les et
ils sont contestés viendront faire un
choix nous sommes en train de travailler
notamment pour remettre en cause un
certain nombre davantage que nous
considérons comme inadaptée aujourd'hui
pas de logement de fonction vous non
plus 7 nous sur nos gens sont sur les
élus ont une indemnité doivent payer
leurs jours pas de vote leur fonction là
aussi les voitures de service quand ils
sont à l'exercice mais ensuite
donc nous voulons réduire toutes ces
dépenses ou de sons du protocole et
s'est réduit parce que nous sommes dans
une situation difficile et mouvement une
forme sobriété dans l'utilisation des
fonds b et douches rassure c'est que
avant même l'expression des jeunes
la commune ne m'amuse pas sienne avons
anticipé là dessus puisque moi j'ai
éliminé battu en fonction nous voyageons
en classe économique puisque c'est le
moins cher
nous avons divisé par trois le budget du
protocole 600000 euros à 200 et cet
argent pour deviser nous l'avons versé
au ccs précisément un peu ce que devant
deux légistes à réduire le standing et
aider davantage ceux qui sont en
difficulté dont je pense que ce message
il est vrai faut aller plus loin pour
travailler et surtout je pense qu'il ya
un mois de délibérations à mode de
concertation qu'on n'a pas encore trop
les conseils de quartier
une phase encore encore dont il faut pas
abandonner parce que c'est nouveau il
faut travailler et puis voir kate
quel mode je dirais de sélection sur
l'hélice comme on pensait tout ça c'est
au coeur de notre foi redonner du
pouvoir aussi sur le budget par exemple
nous nous avons démarré mais petitement
un budget participatif probablement
l'augmentait a augmenté son périmètre
cinq entités et puis petit à petit si je
suis pas demandé fois aussi quels sont
ceux qui veulent concrètement par ci
parce que la vie d'un élu et ses 365
jours six années c'est pas comme ça un
coup de coeur et puis après on saura
donc il faut ça mais l'interrogation
régit les jeunes ont posé des beaucoup
de questions mais certaines sont fondées
elle nous interpelle parce que
effectivement démocratie et souffrant de
maladies qu'il fout là revigoré parce
que en dehors de la démocratie sur la
dictature
donc il faut réussir démocratie vous y
croyez suffisamment pour être et
fonctionnement de nouveaux candidats
m'avait dit avant tant les chaussées je
dois vous la poser est ce coup là nous
avons un séminaire d'élus samedi
prochain nous la priorité aujourd'hui
c'est de bien finir notre travail à nous
ils auraient six mois un peu plus
donc nous nous voulons nous engager à
l'équipe municipale pour finir et tenir
nos engagements
ensuite dans cette période 10 octobre
novembre
certains aux stars nous ont pas du tout
au plus nous sommes en action tous les
jours s'occupe de ce niveau c'est pas
trop tarder où nous devons nous aurait
aidés mais avant de penser à la
prochaine élection
il faut s'occuper pleinement du groupe
et nous sommes en train de régler à les
dossiers les problèmes pour réussir pour
avoir un bon bilan pour avoir faire la
preuve que à nous étions sérieux que
nous avons fait ce que nous avons dit et
que les deuxièmes peuvent constater la
réalité ça si ça vous après votre
province tant le débat est ouvert nous
continuerons ce débat je vous ai dit
octobre mais il n'y a pas de
précipitation avoir tous les cas il faut
d'abord réussir ce mandat dans lequel
nous sommes
ça fait rumeurs persistantes parlent de
didier robert comme candidat à saint
denis ça fera d'abord un bon adversaire
et ensuite un beau père et moi je veux
pas me prononcer là dessus et rubber
c'est tous les candidats admettons qu'il
raconte doigt est ce que vous êtes ce
que ça c'est pour voir l'adversaire et
se séparent saint denis resserre bon
j'ai pas griffes y exiger robert hayes
est présent dans la région aujourd'hui
son mandat s'arrête un jour
en fin de 2021 donc là de quoi faire
mais peu importe qu'ils soient qu'ils
sont pas nous nous y ait ensuite nous
affronterons tous les candidats lui les
autres un et nous devons être prêts et
comme seul sortant et co-président
présent de région ils vous donnent
l'impression d'être à sa place et que
après tout s'ils gagnent les élections à
saint denis
j'irai aussi la mairie non on peut pas
être à la région et a pris l'engagement
et à la mérite sunice même nom mais
suivant c'est pas possible
en mai chaleur ça c'est impossible et
moi je suis dans l'opposition de gauche
pourrait me donner une autre émission
d'une heure pour que je vous dise toutes
les critiques que je frôle régulièrement
sur la politique régionale de votre
sujet qui vous préoccupe par exemple
l'échec des jeux olympiques je pense que
la chaîne course part de responsabilité
je suis déçu c'est moi je désire on
pourra en parler de sujets en reparler
dans cette émission on est bien il
expliqué autre souplesse légendaire vous
permet de faire le grand écart entre le
parti socialiste et la chronique
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas je
travaille ma souplesse quotidiennement
je vous le dis je fais qu'une heure et
demie de médias est de mieux 2
yoga et de méditation par jour mais
comme beaucoup d'autres et c'est pas ça
le problème
le problème c'est que moi je suis le
maire du 2 d'une alliance avec notamment
un groupe
elle a alors quitté les jours non une
personne qui l'a été dans l'opposition
ont conçu un groupe et on râle rallier
la majorité dont j'ai dans ma majorité
un groupe essentiellement des
socialistes et des verts et vous serez
les champs pour l'élection
présidentielle face à marine le pen et à
l'éventualité de fillon à l'époque dont
je considérais que face aux d'orge et
marine le pen est et on risque fillon
quitté terrible si vous voulez supprimer
ça semble fonctionner donc moi j'ai fait
partie mais qui proposait de donner un
revenu universel y compris adam de
bettencourt non je partageais pas à
cette vision dont j'ai fait ce choix
souvent là aujourd'hui a aujourd'hui on
va plutôt parler de bilan puis jonathan
président a effectué un certain nombre
de mesures
il a eu un certain nombre de
comportements dont évidemment le bilan
est plus mitigé problème je suis plus
réservé en particulier sur la politique
ou travers je considère que le président
n'ait pas pris la mesure des problèmes
outre-mer que la politique du
gouvernement outre-mer est mauvaise a
notamment sur l'emploi chance à prendre
deux mesures donc puisque le chômage a
augmenté alors qu'il ait dit miller ne
font pas les connaissent aussi c'est bon
oui je lui dis très très très réservé
sur les actions du président du
gouvernement veut leur dire à me
chercher je rapport avec des conseillers
du présent j'en ai eu il ya quelques
mois et je lui dis tout pas la partie de
ma déception milliers des choses
damman le dédoublement des classes et
des bonnes réformes aussi dont je veux
pas être là je pète tout négatives ou
positives mais je suis réservé et sur la
politique
outre-mer du président et du
je considère qu'elle n'est pas bonne
elle est très très mauvaise il faut la
corriger
l'université se tenait alors j'ai le ce
souk n est ce que le parti socialiste
encore un message à faire passer aux
électeurs ou est ce qui est condamné à
disparaître définitivement des radars à
cesser leur jeu aujourd'hui par
socialisme et je sais que vous souhaitez
qu'il survive a bien sûr il a une
histoire qui marche
il n'aura peut-être pas le rôle qu'il a
joué bien sûr est le premier run
je pense qu'aujourd'hui est de un
mouvement qui france retrait car
l'europe et dans l'euro et auquel on est
censé le mouvement autour du climat du
développement solidaire a non je pense
que cette mouvance un rôle à jouer
parlons politique générale tous deux
gros tout le monde est à paul et les
écoulements sont un peu plus cette
problématique
sa pose et je crois que les jeunes ont
raison la porte et je suis très heureux
de voir l'éruption de ces jeunes sur la
scène publique politique
interpellés les anciens parce que le
danger réel à le danger des catastrophes
climatique donc il faut s'en préoccuper
donc il faut que le ps bien sûr au
travail son projet les autres et qu'on
trouve une forme de rassemblement des
forces de progrès je pense que dans ce
cas là le ps le ps eni spa et surtout
elle et sensibilité sociale que n'ont
pas d'autres partis si vous repartirez
en 2011 avec les peurs du ps ont pour
l'instant c'est trop trouve un truc à
moi
aujourd'hui comme hier depuis 89 je
conduis une coalition un très large
je pense que pour gérer les problèmes
d'une ville il faut pas être sectaire il
faut passer après l'investiture de this
is a cassé le parti suisse qui se posera
dans tous les cas moi je rassemblerai
probable que je parte et très largement
parce que je pense que c'est nécessaire
il faut toutes les sensibilités
il ne faut pas qu'un mouvement s'empare
d'une sensibilité pour déchets cette
dernière change un décompte publié le
rapport de lacunes de sa demande de
fiabilité des comptes de non respect le
comptable de difficultés autour de die
agents du corps océan à l'autre par
d'opacité de l'autre tour du personnel
oui qu'on vit sa recharge ou alors oui
bah la justice emprunter il est temps de
prendre des mesures
oui je dis d'abord changer des comptes
est dans son rôle moi je respecte le
change constants plier la démocratie il
faut respecter sont des magistrats dont
je respecte
après il ya l'exploitation polémique ne
soit pas là et les recommandations sont
fondées d'air dans un mois je me propose
d'apporter des réponses précises sur
certain nombre de choses qui sont
indiqués sur les 30 du cabinet sur
certaines procédures
on va bien sûr observée sur le cabinet
par exemple ce qui nous est reproché au
cabinet le protocole la communication
donc déjà où vous mettez rejet ils ont
déjà changé ça aujourd'hui le protocole
d'échangé à une partie avec la direction
n'était pas donc nous sommes en train
d'observer de mettre en oeuvre ça c'est
la première sur la fiabilité des gros
celui qui a répondu c'est le comptable
public
conseil municipal
artistes locaux et dit que nos comptes
était allé de mieux en mieux et que nous
avons dégagé un excédent de près de 10
millions dans dans l'exercice de lui
donc nous nous avons des comptes
équilibrés
après il ya l'utilisation fume c'est
normal pour les mii par nos adversaires
que vous essayez sur l'occasion
ouais mais parfois elle va très loin
pour les mic alors après faut ramener
les choses sont l'occasion d'abord de
dire oui il était petit
sauf que je vais vous dire je regarde
rapport la chambre sur deux communes
c'est vraiment et pas comparaison donc
ça ni à une bonne situation financière
par rapport au projet la chaume dit oui
mes deux mains pour faire et bien demain
nous aviserons et nous avons nous des
sous il chante et qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui dans la chambre se préoccupe
de son fera demain quand il faudra
porter les grands projets nous avons
réfléchi et nous apportons des réponses
est ce qu'il ya des au delà de deux de
ces ajustements sur le fait que vous
avez reconnu des irrégularités son
recrutement dans les salaires dans les
marchés publics du tout écouter non
travaillés il faut bien chaque mot a un
sens aux irrégularités peut-être des
malversations dont aucune
d'ailleurs nous chanson kids la
malhonnêteté y est pas ça ceux ci
étaient ses erreurs techniques
administratives et je vais vous donner
un exemple clair que nous aucun marché
public de la ville de sénilité kassian
10 ans et devant une masse de marché
j'ai de la ville et 300 millions par an
dont pas sondé et marché plus aucun
marché nous avons par an 5 ou 6
personnes acteurs économiques ihs qui ne
gagne pas un appel off et qui ont un
recours ils ont tous perdu
donc moi je félicite la direction des
professionnels qui garantit et m'ont élu
donc nous faisons des petits achats le
protocole c'est vrai que nous avons
acheté telle qualité de produit elle
changea de contout dit non il faut
globalisé appels d'offres à un
restaurateur un fournisseur
deux sens on va faire des détails ça
comparé ces même pas 1% de marchés
publics donc on va pas on va mettre de
l'ordre dans ses pattes les serres sur
lui vous les ressources humaines a oui
oui selon les fausses l'annoncé comme
sur la cantine ont un vrai différend la
chambre aussi dire qu'on ne devrait pas
faire là la cantine gratuite nous nous
considérons qu'à la réunion et être
offre plus de pauvres en france trois
fois plus de chômage non mais dès lors
que toi la chambre considère qu'on
aurait coûté les fonctionnaires il ya
des liens des ja le là là là changer le
compte d'icade est écarté de processus
de recrutement alors qu'elle devrait en
rapport avec ce qu'ils ont occasionnées
est-ce que ça va être obligé nous allons
écrire charge du recrutement
c'est vrai que nous nous avons préféré
que de prendre des fonctionnaires à 53%
sur la liste d'aptitude nous faisons
tomber cdd et nous recruterons décédé
compenser ce qui était contestée et
tribunal nous a repris là dessus at et
c'est qu'au bout de deux ans nous
passions les cdd
la loi demande que 106 ans en jamais
obtenu d'un précédent sous préfet à
monsieur ben retient de le faire en deux
ans pourquoi parce que quand vous passez
on s'est dit c'est plus la précarité
ces agents sont libres et c'est donc moi
je pensais qu'il était préférable qu'ils
passent on s'est dit les lois
aujourd'hui nous sommes trop souvent aux
courses la sphère étrange ici nous
plierons bien sûr à la loi mais nous
pensons que le fait de consolider des
cdd en cdi
c'est la meilleure solution et c'est
préférable pour des emplois ou la
qualification et bout des seins des
emplois d'un semestre à 6 jeux recruter
des asem charlie je serai obligé de
recruter des as qu'elle est de marseille
de toulouse et c'est parce qu'elles sont
sur la liste
et moi je ne veux pas je pense que
suffisamment de chômage pour recruter
les asem en cdd un cdi en faisant de
recrutement local
voilà donc nous sommes en divers champs
j'assume et nous allons discuter d'une
charte de recrutement pour enlever tout
ce qui peut apparaître
le favoritisme et c'est pourquoi ce que
la notion de corps oui c'est un chant
qui le dit mais à partir du moment où on
a un jury qu'on exige des compétences
dans un pays où il ya énormément de
choix quand vous recrutez cas quand les
disent qu'ils n'ont pas en tout et il
estime que c'est pas normal qu'ils
auraient dû être donc est toujours en
cure d'édition favoritisme quand par les
personnes qui sont pas ôté mon truc à
nous voulons organiser ça nous sommes en
train de travailler sur une charte pour
justement épuré tout cela qui n'est plus
cette suspicion de fabrice dans les
sujets qui fâchent égale mois
il ya le réseau national maillot qui
était celui même qui l'avait construit
sur des terrains qui n'étaient pas
constructibles vous rendre clair vous
dites quoi on parle et d'exemplarité
tout à leurs attentes du citoyen son
équipe a été élue qu'est ce que c'est
que les gens d'abord cette affaire a
démarré en 2007 et au moral bayonetta
élus et problème puisque j'étais loin de
lui mais c'est vrai c'est pas exemplaire
lui même a reconnu qu'il a fait une
erreur
jal maillot vert c'est erreurs mais
réduire cherhal maillot à cette erreur
c'est oublié c'est le porter le présent
ainsi nord qui portent des projets
fantastique 1 et téléphérique le tramway
donc à chaque fois
moi je ne veux pas compté ses achats bio
a commis une erreur lui même l'a confié
il géra salle à la justice et pour ses
deux moteurs mais à côté de ça gérald
maillot est un formidable élus pour vous
disent pas grave non je ne dis pas c'est
pas grave je dis que gérald maillot ne
se résume pas c'était ok plein chose
qu'il a réalisé qu'ils sont hainard moi
je le connais pas 40 ans comme toutes
les diverses mais quand on july faudrait
je pense qu'il faut que ce soit qui gère
ça les conséquences de sa macabre qu'à
côté de ça court ne réduit pas à
l'action de gérald maillot à ça il ya
beaucoup choses fantastiques je vous
parle de la gestion des ordures et la
magnifique projet il a ce projet tramway
qui révolutionnèrent le téléphérique
c'est lui qui le port dont je dis qu'à
côté de cette fois c'était la roue du
lieu il a su moi il ya le res et il
reste montre qui a beaucoup donné
beaucoup apporté à la collectivité donc
ce que roy à l'évaluer le front tenant
compte des deux jeux de joindre la
situation à saugnac la société d'une
hygiène adjoint de construction elle est
en difficulté du fait que les
trésoreries
le personnel aussi croire que les dunes
espérer un jour avoir un logement
je pense aussi les l'organisent un des
organes y construire ce sujet est en
difficulté avec un petit opacité sur ce
qu'il yac'est tweet bailleurs sociaux à
non la sodiac en difficulté l'air était
en difficulté a été reprise par la fia
la clé pour la sidèrent 50 contre la
semader la cedh rex et la loi la loi
c'est pas la réunion la loi la loi
française élan a imposé en quelque sorte
au à ce qu'on appelle les bailleurs
sociaux de se regrouper pour havas au
minimum quinze mille jours la sonnette
n'a que 3500 et les difficultés de la
sonia deviennent à la fois de la nature
de son action puisque elle achète des
terrains qu'elle essaie de valoriser
après construire et que les recettes
sont parfois décalés de 5 10 ans et ados
un besoin de trésorerie importants donc
les banquiers notamment la caisse des
dépôts vont venir la sodiac va l
apprendre une opacité il ya pas de nom
sais pas si c'est toujours pas été créée
rapport il n'y a pas de problème
d'opacité il n'y a pas de problème
surtout de malversations il ya eu un
bilan en incendiant certifiés par un
commissaire aux comptes à gré où elle a
dégagé un excédent mais ya un problème
de trésorerie terre entre l'argent par
exemple ce terrain qu'elle a acheté 7
millions e à anciennement d'anti royal
ce terrain ben il est gelé parce que le
projet a été bloqué par rapport à prunay
l'oncle projet sortira dans quatre cinq
ans mais pendant ce temps il faut
rembourser les emprunts qu'on a fait
prochain c'est un problème technique de
13 ans qui est difficile donc la
chaudière est en train de négocier avec
des banques et de la caisse des dépôts
pour conformément à la loi
rentré dans un ensemble qui courte au
moins 15000 au vent c'est une
restructuration
je vous cite une retraite interventions
on va voir sans jouer
je vous dit et pour illustrer ça c'est
le plus grand agents économiques l'avion
ce monsieur jacques de chateauvieux il
est aujourd'hui monsieur jacques de
chateauvieux une de ces entreprises a
été mis en redressement judiciaire en
grave grave
pourtant personne pourra évoquer
l'incompétence de monsieur qui est un
chef hors cadre pour l'armement au sucre
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé eh bien
il a bâti stratégie un développement sur
une tendance d'accroissement du
transport métier et se trouve que le
transport maritime ne croit plus des
croix et bien il n'a pas prévu
aujourd'hui liquidée en europe et donc
quand on est dans le monde économique on
n'est pas dans la fonction publique est
pas garanti touriste et donc il ya des
éléments qui nous échappe à des
concurrents qui naissent une situation
un contexte dont la sodiac les absorber
face à ça elles sont dans cette
compétition et donc elle elle essaie de
s'adapter elles peuvent que la des
difficultés mais c'est pas parce
qu'elles sont en difficulté qu'elles
sont mal gérées ou qu'il y ait de la
malversation parce que ce qui est
évidemment font semblant de s'appuyer là
dessus pour critiquer ils n'ont pas ils
disent pas la vérité et non pas la vraie
connaissance c'est aussi parler de la
rentrée scolaire vous soutenez vous le
v10 le dédoublement des classes on sait
les zones d'éducation prioritaire
d'abord pourquoi pas de mon compte tenu
de l'état la réunion était comment et
quand est ce que vous en tant que maire
vous pousse à face au au doublement des
nations notamment s'encrasse on a le
bilan du son a dédoublé toutes les
classes de l'éducation prioritaire à 60
% des écoles c'est nice en zone
d'éducation prioritaire nous avons des
doublés et construit une vingtaine de
classes donc nous avons répondu que nous
transformons projet qu'on voulait pas
priver les enfants de cette qualité
aujourd'hui les premiers résultats
montrent bien que cp à 12 sa des
résultats les élèves à prendre bien
derrière et j'ai visité avec le mini
sans corps des écoles etc étaient
confiants c'est une bonne réforme
qu'est ce que l'on fait on enlève des
crédits ailleurs pour
sur l'école on a aujourd'hui 40
catégories merci ni sur le label école
numérique avec l'eau avec des voix là
avec des tablettes et ça pourquoi parce
que nous voulons que nos enfants soient
dans le peloton de tête nous nos enfants
soit voilà soit en avance bien il nous
mettons le paquet évidemment on grignote
ailleurs on supprime ailleurs des choses
peuvent changer quoi parce qu est-ce que
vous en fin peu sur les roues sur des
choses à cacher a les roues de la
moindre goutte d'eau dans mon métier en
place et amis ont donc un milieu qu'on
était dans les écoles sa porte et nous
nous pensons que la priorité des
priorités c'est la réussite éducative
élever le niveau de tous les enfants et
en particulier ils m'auraient pas en
pierre toutes les bibliothèques ceni
était ouverte dimanche après-midi
gratuite pour inviter les enfants les
parents à amener leurs enfants militait
pour la lecture
or quand nous ou hanche après midi ça
nous coûte plus cher parce que il faut
le travail du dimanche et et surpayés
donc nous surveillons le personnel pour
l'intérêt des enfants
merci je vais voir avec le mot ce midi
lors lundi politique en france il doit
vous nous direz l'entente voulu si vous
êtes candidat à votre propre succession
pour les élections municipales qui se
tiendront en mars et 15 et 22 mars je
crois me disent vous ne direz si vous
êtes comme daouda remercie d'avoir raté
merci à vous
lundi politique gaël le dantec pourriez
vous citer les derniers médicaments que
l'on vous a prescrit et ceux de l'année
dernière
la question ne se posera plus quand vous
avez ouvert votre dossier médical
partagé qu'il n'est pas toujours simple
de vous souvenir précisément de toutes
vos informations de santé vaccin
allergies examen ou médicaments que l'on
vous a prescrit et au dossier médical
partagé gardera absolument tout en
mémoire pour vous ouvrez vite votre dmp
en pharmacie ou sur des mtf rdnp la
mémoire de votre santé l'assurance
maladie
[Musique]
oui
ak
[Musique]
tu peux
soit
[Musique]
ils ont tous